welcome back everyone this is the Sixth
and final screencast in our series on
methods and metrics we're going to talk
about model evaluation this is a high
level discussion that is directly
oriented toward helping you with your
final project work
here's an overview we're going to talk
about baselines what are they why are
they important
we'll talk about the trials and
tribulations of hyper perimeter
optimization and why it's important
we'll think about classifier comparison
a common mode to be in as you're
evaluating systems and hypotheses and
then we'll talk about two things that
are really particular to the Deep
learning era how to assess models that
don't converge in any strict sense and
also the role of random parameter
initialization in the performance of our
biggest models
let's start with baselines we take this
for granted but this is actually pretty
important conceptually here's a
fundamental observation about baselines
evaluation numbers in our field can
never be understood properly in
isolation
suppose your system gets 0.95 F1 you
feel Overjoyed but the first question
reviewers will ask you is is the task
too easy how do simple bass lines do on
the problem
conversely suppose your system gets 0.6
and you feel in despair
because you feel like you haven't had a
success here but the next question
should be how do humans do they're
presumably a kind of upper bound and if
it's a hard task or a noisy task Human
Performance might be close to 0.61 and
you might really have to achieved
something meaningful there so it's
Baseline models and in that case Oracle
models that are helping us to understand
baselines are also crucial for strong
experimental design right so defining
your Baseline should not be some
afterthought but rather Central to how
you define your overall hypotheses think
about simple systems think about
ablations of your target system and
incorporate those into your thinking
about the comparisons that you'll make
and baselines are really just one aspect
of the comparisons we want to offer
baselines are essential for building a
persuasive case we saw that in my two
examples there to really understand and
calibrate on what you achieved we need
some baselines to kind of calibrate all
of that stuff
they can also be used to illuminate
specific aspects of the problem and
specific Virtues Of Your proposed system
that often falls under the heading of
ablations of your system those are
baselines that remove crucial features
or components and test the model with
the same protocol and then the distance
between your chosen model and the
ablated model is a kind of estimate of
the importance of the ablated component
to the overall system performance
crucial aspect of arguing and supporting
hypotheses and everything else
random baselines are really useful for
many purposes first they can provide a
really true lower bound on how systems
can do on your problem sometimes they
are surprisingly robust and so it's
worth running these early and I think
also they can help you kind of fully
debug your system these are probably
lightweight models that do relatively
little processing and can make sure that
everything is kind of functioning and
makes sense and all that other stuff
scikit learn again has you covered they
have dummy classifier and dummy
regressor they have different ways of
acting as random models and I think this
is really useful to set up early in your
process
you could also think about task specific
baselines this might require real
thought and real study in the literature
does your problem suggest a baseline
that will reveal something about the
problem or the way it's modeled if so
you should have one of these tasks
specific baselines here are two recent
examples from nlu the first one is
natural language inference people
discovered that so-called hypothesis
only baselines can be very strong
the reason this happens is that in the
underlying crowdsourcing effort crowd
workers were given premise sentences and
asked to construct three hypotheses one
for neutral one for contradiction and
one for entailment in that process of
construction they did some systematic
things that kind of convey information
about the label inadvertently through
the hypothesis for example many
contradictions involve negation and many
entailment pairs involve very general
terms as part of the hypothesis what
that means is that the hypothesis
actually carries information about the
label and a hypothesis only Baseline
quantifies that you simply fit a model
without any premise information and see
how you do and the finding of the
literature is that very often for our
benchmarks the hypothesis only Baseline
is way above chance and what that shows
you is that the random Baseline is not
so informative anymore
there's a similar story for the story
closed task this is to distinguish
between a coherent and incoherent ending
for a story and again systems that look
only at the ending often do really well
I think for the same reason the coherent
versus incoherent thing is often
actually inferable just from the ending
neglecting the story so it's not that
the the task is broken here necessarily
but rather again that you should think
about this as a baseline to compare
against and progress is really progress
from this very specialized Baseline
next topic hyper perimeter optimization
this is discussed extensively in one of
our background units on sentiment
analysis you might go there for a
refresher here I'll just briefly review
the rationale you want maybe to obtain
the best version of your model and that
might mean exploring over different
hyper parameters to find a kind of
optimal setting for it
another motivation is about comparison
between models suppose you do have a
results table full of different systems
you're comparing it makes no sense to
compare them against randomly chosen
parameter settings because you really
want to give every model the best chance
to shine otherwise there's an
arbitrariness to the evaluation that
might not translate into robust results
so what you really do is give every
system a chance by exploring a wide
range of hyper parameters and Reporting
the optimal results according to that
exploration that's a fair comparison and
it implies a lot of search over hyper
parameters you might want to understand
the stability of your architecture this
is interestingly different this is where
you're not interested in the best
parameters but rather how stable system
performance is under various choices
people might make in order to get a
sense for how robustly it will perform
if people are saying not attentive to
these hyper parameters or set them
incorrectly in a kind of inadvertent
accident or an adversarial setting
crucial to all of this no matter what
your goals hyper parameter tuning must
be done only on train and development
data you never do model selection of any
kind based on the test data this is a
special case of the rule that I've been
repeating throughout the course this is
really fundamental to how we think about
testing and generalization and it
applies with real force in the context
of the kind of model selection we're
doing here
now hyper parameter optimization has
gotten really challenging in the era of
long-running expensive training regimes
and let me give you a sense for what the
problem is by way of an example
for each hyper parameter you identify a
large set of values for it in some range
then you create a list of all the
combinations of all the hyper parameters
this is the cross product of all the
values for all the features you
identified in step one which you can
hear in that description is an
exponential growth in the number of
settings
for each setting you cross validate it
on the available training data which
might imply 5 or 10 or 20 experiments
then you choose the settings that did
best in step 3 and you train on all the
train data using that setting and then
you evaluate that model on the test set
that is a kind of pristine version of
the protocol that we might be
implementing
but here's the problem suppose parameter
H1 has five values and parameter two has
ten
then the total number of settings is now
50.
suppose we add three then it goes to a
hundred
now suppose we're going to do five-fold
cross validation to select optimal
parameters and now we are at 500 runs
very quickly the number of experiments
exploded and if each one of these runs
takes a day you're pretty much out of
contention in terms of actually
implementing this protocol completely
something has to change
all right the above is untenable as a
set of laws for the scientific Community
we cannot insist on this level of hyper
parameter optimization if we adopted it
complex model strained on large data
sets would end up disfavored and only
the very wealthy would be able to
participate and to give you a glimpse of
this here's a quote from a paper from a
team at Google doing kind of NLP for
Health Care the performance of All Above
neural networks were tuned automatically
using Google vizier with a total of over
200 000 GPU hours that is a lot of money
spent on a lot of compute obviously we
cannot insist on a similar level of
investment for experiments say for this
course but frankly for any contribution
in the field we have to have compromises
so here are some reasonable compromises
these are pragmatic steps you can take
to alleviate this resource problem I've
given them in descending order of
attractiveness and I find that as the
days go by we need to go lower and lower
on this list
you could do random sampling and guided
sampling to explore a large space on a
fixed budget this is kind of nice
because you have the cross product of
all of the settings that's too large you
simply randomly sample in the space
Maybe with some guidance from a model
and you can then on a fixed budget of
say five or ten or a hundred runs do a
version of the phone grid search
you could also search based on a few
epochs of training the expense comes
from multiple epochs maybe you do one or
two and then you pick the hyper
parameters that were best at that point
and if the learning curves are kind of
familiar and consistent then this will
be a pretty strong approach here
you could also search based on subsets
of the data this is fine but it could be
risky because we know some parameters
are very dependent on data set size and
so you're selecting based on small data
and applying it to large data even
though you know that's probably a risky
assumption
you could do heuristic search and Define
which hyper parameters matter less and
then set them by hand and justify that
in the paper that's increasingly Common
People describe things like we
determined in our initial experiments
that these hyper parameters had this
optimal value or didn't matter that much
and so we chose these reasonable values
and then the actual search happens only
over the ones that you kind of can tell
are important we have to take your word
for it that you've done the heuristic
search responsibly but this is obviously
a really good way to balance Exploration
with constrained resources
you could find the optimal hyper
parameters via a single split and use
them for all subsequent splits and then
justify that based on the fact that the
splits are similar that would
automatically cut down substantially on
the number of runs you need to do
because you don't need to do so much
cross validation in this mode
and then finally you could adopt others
choices right and the Skeptics will
complain that these findings don't
translate to new data sets but it could
be the only option and as I say a few
years ago this was kind of frowned upon
but now in the modern era with these
massive models it's basically the only
option and so I think increasingly
people are simply carrying forward other
hyper parameters it means less
exploration we might not be seeing the
best versions of these models but it
might then again be the only option
in terms of tools for hyper parameter
search as always scikit is really rich
with these things they've got a lot of
these toolings and in addition scikit
optimize is kind of one level up in
terms of sophistication that's where you
could do model guided search through a
hyper parameter Grid in order to
intelligently select good settings to
lead to a good model on a fixed budget
next topic classifier comparison this is
a short one but this can be important
suppose you've assessed two classifier
models their performance is probably
different in some way what can you do to
establish whether these models are
different in any meaningful sense I
think there are a few options the first
would be practical differences if they
obviously make a large number of
different predictions you might be able
to quantify that difference in terms of
some actual external outcome that's a
really good scenario to be in
you could also think about confidence
intervals to further bolster the
argument that you're making this will
give us a picture of how consistently
different the two systems are and if
they are consistently different then you
have a very clear argument in favor of
one over the other
the wilcoxon sign rank test is a kind of
accepted method in the field for
assessing classifiers using
methodologies that are similar to
standard t-tests and I guess the
consensus is just that the assumptions
behind the wilcoxon test are somewhat
more aligned with classifier comparison
to do that as well as confidence
intervals you will have had to run your
model on lots of different settings to
get a long Vector of 10 to 20 scores to
use as the basis for the stats testing
if that is too expensive you could opt
with for mcnemars test this is a
comparison that you do over two single
trained classifiers based on their
confusion matrices so you only need one
run it will be kind of unstable if the
models are unstable but it is a way of
doing a stats test in the kind of mode
of the chi-squared test to give you some
information about how two fixed
artifacts compare to each other not as
strong as the previous methods but
nonetheless useful and arguably better
than nothing
okay a special topic for deep learning
how do you assess models without
convergence this never used to arise
back in the days of all linear models
all these models would converge more or
less instantly to Epsilon loss and then
you could feel like that was how you'd
move forward with assessing them
right but now with neural networks
convergence has really taken center
stage and it's in a complicated way that
it takes Center Stage first these models
rarely converge to Epsilon loss and
therefore it's kind of non-issue whether
or not that would be your stopping
Criterion in addition they might
converge at different rates between runs
and their performance on the test set
might not even be especially related to
how small the loss got
so you need to be kind of thoughtful
about exactly what your stopping
criteria will be yeah sometimes a model
with low final error turns out to be
great and sometimes it's worse than the
one that finished with a higher error
this might have something to do with
overfitting and regularization but the
bottom line here is we don't know
apriori what's going on this is very
experiment driven
so one thing to think about for stopping
criteria in general is what we call
incremental devset testing to address
the kind of uncertainty that I just
reviewed you regularly collect
information about devset performance as
part of the training that you're doing
for example at every 100th iteration you
could make predictions on the dev set
and store the resulting Vector of
predictions
all the pie torch models for this course
have an early stopping parameter and a
bunch of related parameters that will
help you set this up in a way that will
allow you to do this incremental testing
and with luck get the best model
and if you need a little bit of
motivation for this here are some plots
from an actual model you can see the
loss going down very steadily across
different iterations of training but the
performance on the devset Tells A very
different story you can see based on
this performance that at a certain very
early point in this process around
iteration 10 our performance was
actually getting worse even though the
loss was going down and that just shows
you that sometimes this steady loss
curve is a picture of overfitting and
not of your model actually getting
better at the thing that you care about
so think carefully about your stopping
criteria and in general though I think
we might want to take a more expansive
view of how we do evaluation in this
mode here what I'm pitching is that we
look at the entire performance curve
maybe with confidence intervals so we
can make some confident distinctions all
these plots for different conditions
across models we were comparing have
epochs along the x-axis and F1 along the
y-axis and if you step back what I think
you see is that our mittens model the
one that we were kind of advocating for
is the best model on average but largely
in early parts of training if you train
for long enough a lot of the
distinctions disappear
so if you have a fixed budget of epochs
mittens is a good choice if you don't
care about the resources it might not be
so clear which one you should choose
maybe it doesn't matter that's a nuanced
lesson that I think is really powerful
to teach and we can't really teach it if
all we do is offer Point estimates of
model performance we really need to see
the full curve to see that level of
nuance and so I know that nlpers love
their results tables you should have
results tables but maybe you could
supplement them with some figures that
would give us a fuller picture of what
was going on
final topic the role of random parameter
initialization most deep learning models
have parameters that are random at the
start even if they're pre-trained
they're usually some random parameters
in the mix there
this is clearly meaningful for the kind
of non-convex problems that we're posing
simpler models can be impacted as well
but it's especially pressing in the Deep
learning era and here is a relatively
recent paper showing actually that
different initializations for neural
sequence models led to statistically
significant differences in performance
and so a number of recent systems were
actually indistinguishable in terms of
their raw performance once we took the
source of variation into account
there's a related issue here of
catastrophic failure from unlucky
initializations sometimes that happens
sometimes you see it sometimes it's hard
to notice
there's a question of how to report that
as part of overall system performance we
need to be reflective about this and
maybe the bottom line here is just for
the associated notebook for this unit
evaluation methods I just showed you
with the classic xor problem which has
always been used to motivate the
powerful models that we work with now
that you don't actually get success for
a simple feed forward Network for that
problem 8 out of 10 times it succeeds
and two out of the ten times it's a
colossal failure that is a glimpse of
just how important initialization can be
and since we don't analytically
understand why we're seeing this
variation the best response if you can
afford it is a bunch more experiments
all right let's wrap up a lot of this in
the back of my mind is oriented toward
helping you with the protocols which is
a document associated with your final
project where you give us the nuts and
bolts of the project and try to identify
any obstacles to success so all the
lessons we've been teaching throughout
this series are oriented toward helping
you think critically about this protocol
and ultimately set up a firm foundation
for your project
with that out of the way I thought I
would look ahead to this moment and the
future I think this is an ideal moment
for Innovation and surprising new places
architecture Innovation Way overrated at
this point I mean it's still important
but it is overrated relative to the
amount of things people do metric
Innovation Way underrated it's been a
theme of these lectures that we need to
think very carefully about our metrics
because they are our guidepost toward
whether we're succeeding or not
relatedly evaluations in general we need
Innovation there this is way underrated
by the community at this point task
Innovation underrated we're seeing some
things so it's not as bad as two and
three but still we should all be
participating in this area and then
finally exhaustive hyper parameter
search you need to weigh this against
other factors there is more at play here
than just that pristine scientific
Paradigm we need to think about costs in
every sense and how it relates to the
kind of innovations that we're likely to
see so I'm pitching a pragmatic approach
but I'm also exhorting you to think
expansively about how you might
participate in pushing the field forward